395 and the roman empire has been split
in two
this was done by emperor theodosius the
first known also as theodosius the great
because he defeated the goths and made
the official religion of the empire
christianity
he did this in a very clever way by
banning all of the others
the empire's two halves were to be
inherited by theodosius sons
arcadius received the eastern half
centered at constantinople and anorius
received the west centered at medeolanum
in case you're wondering rome was seen
as the spiritual capital of the entire
empire and it's important to note that
the empire wasn't officially divided
those who controlled the two halves saw
themselves as joint rulers of a single
empire but realistically they were run
as separate entities at this point
as a whole the empire had a population
of about 40 million people and was
fairly urbanized
rome was the largest city and had a
population between 350 000 and half a
million but the east as a whole was much
more urbanized the major urban centers
there
included the likes of constantinople
antioch alexandria and corinth
feeding the masses of roman
constantinople required what was called
the grain doll
this was where wheat was imported from
the fertile regions of north africa and
egypt to the cities at great cost to the
imperial treasury
this was part of the bread and circus's
mantra whereby feeding and entertaining
people meant that they would shut up and
not riot the entertainment was mostly
paid for by the wealthy but after 404
this entertainment would no longer
include gladiatorial combat
this was because the monk telemachus
tried to stop a fight between gladiators
and was promptly murdered
anorius moved by this banned
gladiatorial combat because it was
unchristian and apparently not okay to
watch people maim each other for our
entertainment
so another major expense to the treasury
was of course the army which numbered
between 400 and 500
000 men this was extremely expensive and
required an extensive tax system and
bureaucracy to make sure the army was
paid on time since if the army wasn't
paid on time they tended to revolt
both halves of the empire suffered with
many problems corruption rebellion
financial crises and perhaps most
notably barbarian invasions
side note the term barbarian will be
used to describe non-latin or
greek-speaking peoples who originated
from outside of the empire
there were loads of barbarian groups
that the romans had to deal with but the
main ones were the celts the franks the
vandals the ostrogoths the visigoths and
later on the huns
the eastern empire was wealthier than
the west but had to share a border with
the extremely potent sassanian empire
meaning that it can never bring its full
force to bear unless they face a
deadlier invasion
nominally the western empire was run by
an aurius but the real power lay in a
man called flavius stiliko who was born
to a vandal father and a roman mother
i.e he was a barbarian or at least was
seen to be by his peers
this was not a rare occurrence since
there were many groups of barbarians
that had been allowed to settle within
the empire and the condition that they
fight for it
the romans rarely held up their end of
the bargain though and this led to many
barbarian groups revolting the most
notable example of this
occurred in 378 when the agreement
between fritigen and his goths and the
roman emperor valens wasn't honored
fritigen revolted and defeated the
romans at the battle of adrian oppel in
which valens was killed
surely after this though the romans
would learn to uphold their bargains but
fun fact
no so a visigoth called alaric had been
rampaging across the balkans and in
order to get him to stop he was given an
imperial title and allowed to settle in
a lyrica here he wanted to be closer to
rome rome wanted him to not be closer to
romans so he decided to compromise in
401 when he raised an army and marched
on rome
he was stopped and defeated by stillico
but this invasion did lead to an aureus
moving the capital of the western empire
from mediolanum to ravenna which was
more secure
in 406 another invasion this time led by
a gulf called radagases entered italy he
was also defeated by stiliko but in
order to do so he had to withdraw troops
from the northern border which in
hindsight not a great idea because
immediately after this in came the
vandals who flooded into ghoul
fortunately for stillico things would
quiet down after this by which i mean
they would get considerably worse
in 407 a general in britain declared
himself to be the rightful emperor as
constantine iii
in invaded ghoul stiliko was being
blamed for all of the previous few years
failings and him being half vandalman
that many questioned where his loyalties
lie
as such he was accused of being a
traitor executed and soon afterwards the
romans slaughtered any of his allies and
whatever vandals they could get their
hands on with stylico now a bit on the
dead side things started to get a bit
better for the western empire that was a
lie i'm sorry
alaric made his way back into italy
again and was free to do whatever he
wanted
honoris was getting a bit worried by
this point and so recognized constantine
as his co-ruler to help the situation
it didn't in 410 after his third siege
of the city alaric took rome and
promptly sacked it he was a christian
and so he spared most of the churches
but the city was damaged quite severely
the main damage was to roman prestige
however since rome had remained safe for
800 years
rome was no longer invincible and by
extension neither was her empire in
either the east or the west
after the sack alaric went south where
he promptly died removing at least one
major threat from
the romans it was in this same year that
the people of britannia had complained
of their lack of protection from celtic
raids to anorees he promptly told them
to deal with it
as such britannia's place in the empire
simply fell away and it would never
again be under roman rule
in 411 after failing to secure ghoul or
defeat the barbarians constantine
decided this emperor business wasn't for
him and he abdicated soon after which he
died
of being murdered so the west was
starting to fall apart at this point but
how was the east doing
fine really there was no immediate
prospect of war with the persians and
the wealthiest regions of the empire
were far away from danger in the south
4away did see the death of arcadius and
the succession of his son theodosius ii
though
back in the west the roman army spent
the next decade mopping up the remaining
bands of barbarians as well as any
remaining rebels or usurpers
much of this was done by allowing the
barbarians some semblance of
independence such as when the visigoths
were granted territory here in 418.
by 423 the crisis had subsided and so an
aurier celebrated
by dying and after some arguing he was
succeeded by valentinian iii
theodosius's nephew 4 22 he'd seen the
outbreak of war between the eastern
empire and the sasanians but they agreed
to peace after only a year
with all this in mind it's important to
remember that the vast majority of
romans thought the empire was fine
rome had suffered many civil wars in the
past and had also survived the 3rd
century crisis so there was little
reason to think that this time would be
any different
in the east this certainly seemed to be
the case since it saw the beginnings of
an economic boom which would last until
the 6th century
the issues of the barbarians within the
western empire were growing worse though
with many groups notably the visigoths
and the vandals demanding more territory
valentinian iii was essentially a puppet
to a general named flavius atheists who
failed to deal with the barbarians in
any meaningful way
in fact he had to turn to a new group of
barbarians to help suppress rome's
enemies
the huns led by a certain attila the
huns were a nomadic group of people who
had been pushing west for several
decades at this point forcing other
barbarians to also head west into the
roman empire
80 has made regular use of hunnic
mercenaries to help fight other
barbarian groups which even when it was
successful was only so for a short time
roman success was short-lived since it
was never long until barbarian groups
would rise up again in revolt and start
taking territory by the late 430s the
romans had settled large groups of
barbarians
in ghoul and hispania who were also
essentially independent reducing the
western empire's effective territory to
this
of course the major change occurred when
the vandals led by king gen zurich
settled in north africa in the early
430s and in 439 conquered the city of
carthage this was a major blow to the
western empire since the vandals now
controlled the grain supply to rome and
thus could cut it off whenever it suited
them
furthermore the loss of all of this
territory meant that rome could no
longer raise as much taxes it had done
previously and so it couldn't pay its
troops
soon after the fall of carthage jt has
raised a large force to retake the city
from the vandals but this wasn't to be
since the eastern empire was then
invaded by a massive force of huns so
these troops had to be recalled
in case you're wondering both the east
and west had attempted to help each
other several times before this such as
when the east sent troops to carthage
but generally speaking self-interest won
out over fraternity
so the hanukkah threat had picked up
massively during the 40s as attila had
united the huns and subjugated people
like the ostrogoths
attila's empire looked like this and in
the early 450s he launched a large-scale
invasion of the western empire this
culminated in the 451 battle of the
catalonian fields which saw atheists
command an army mostly made up of
barbarians against the huns
a colossal amount of people died and by
453 the hunted withdrawn from the
western empire
and it was in this same year that attila
died his empire subsequently fell into
civil war and disintegrated fairly
quickly
454 saw the assassination of atheists by
valentinian who the next year was
himself assassinated in the wake of
valentinian's death the west fell into
chaos which saw more territory lost and
roamed sacked again in 455 this time by
gen zurich by 457 the emperor was a man
called mayuri and who actively sought to
reconquer the lost territories within
the west
he had some success with this and
recaptured all of this territory with
the help of his magister militant
rissima
rissima would have miurian assassinated
and would then rule the western empire
as stiliko had through a series of
imperial puppets until his death in 472
there were some more weak emperors in
the west until a man called orestes took
control of it and named his son emperor
as romulus augustus although he's better
known as augustulus which means little
augustus
both of these were soon chased off in
476 by a man called odawasa who forced
romulus to abdicate leaving the imperial
throne vacant in the west
this is with the exception of the former
emperor julius nepot who claimed it but
had no authority
this is by many historians considered to
be the final end of the western roman
empire
in the void it left were many new
kingdoms including the vandals the
visigoths the franks are now in italy
the kingdom of odawasa which pledged its
allegiance to the eastern emperor zeno
zeno would of course have other plans
and task the ostrogothic king theodoric
to retake italy as the eastern empire's
representative which he would do by 493
so the roman empire in the west was now
gone rome lay in ruins and the city
wouldn't really recover until the 19th
century
whilst rome had fallen the roman empire
had not and in the east it stood as
strong as ever
what remained was a highly urbanized
empire which would dominate the eastern
mediterranean and would continue to do
so for another two centuries
with hindsight it's easy to look at what
happened in the west and assume that it
was inevitable
rome had survived many great problems
before but this time it was many
weaknesses combined which led to its
ultimate collapse in the west
whilst the roman empire had disappeared
from western europe her legacy would
endure and would be something
and monarchies alike would aspire to be
over the next millennia or too
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to james bisonette for sponsoring
the channel
if you'd like to know more about the
fall of rome there are some book
recommendations in the description below